usa florida raul weil einst höchster
jubilars vermögensverwalter auf dem weg
ins gericht
umringt von seinen amerikanischen
anwälten erste mal meint realisiert man
gar nicht wichtig was passiert dir auch
logisch märz europa verwendet denn am
nächsten morgen ist einem radio gehört
hat dass sie daran ist eine eigentlich
wirklich erfahrene realisiert ist es
passiert
sie brachten ihn in die usa in anstellen
und mit ketten an den beinen als ob er
ein terrorist der usb stick mit den
daten wurde eine person in der botschaft
in zürich übergeben
es war das wichtigste dokument in diesem
prozess so etwas sieht man im fernsehen
und denkt in einen richtigen trotz es
passiert das nie
[Musik]
raul weil er war jahrelang einer der
mächtigsten banker bis ins jahr 2008
verantwortete er die größte
privatvermögens abteilung der welt dann
beschuldigten die usa des steuerbetrugs
trotzdem reisten er und seine frau susan
leer ich jahrelang unbehelligt ins
ausland ungefähr 2000 in haren usa oder
mini internationaler haftbefehl besteht
und dass ich eine antwort sie dass sich
sehr unwahrscheinlich dass international
ausgeschrieben
bologna im oktober 2013 besuchen die
beiden die italienische kultur statt
sie freuen sich auf ein ruhiges
wochenende
denn in polen hat einen der ersten acht
ist endlos
[Musik]
schreibtischarbeit zweimal gesehen hätte
eine art wollte und dass man sie ins
offene
also eigene zimmer nicht denn die frau
hat reklamiert und eine zweifach kaiser
polizei sofort offen auch
und wenn die boxershorts tanz immer
gestanden und mit einer abfahrt worte
unternehmen also bei nacht und nebel
damit dem polizei alfa romeos im
kommissariat k
es ist zwei uhr morgens sicher vorne
ohne telefon ihres erste telefon und
machte schon bald in amerika zum glück
er starb als sie ihn verhafteten
brachten sie ihn in ein
hochsicherheitsgefängnis außerhalb
londons
es wurde gebaut und terroristen
einzusperren
als sie ihn inhaftierten saßen darin
viele schwerkriminelle serienmörder
gefährliche drogenhändler und so weiter
wird sicher nie vergessen wenn die
zahlen nach oben und hinter mir eine
stahltüre vor der zahlen ins schloss
schnappt unser noch kalt ist wie sony
vermutlich mehr für gas servieren
das ist eine erschreckend der fall wenn
sie doch die huntloser beton gang laufen
und in drei steuergeld dazu sie schon
heimlich so katastrophe zwischen fli und
holt sich sysob als ob sie das neue e10
ist über oft macht machtworten
unternehmen hat von der sektion hat man
auf dem gang hinunterlaufen habe mir
eine von espresso trinken und bin ich
denn der neue vw ist dort mit gong und
euch einfach mal auf den acht
freundlicheren unterfranken seiten zu
mir dass ich zwei eiskalte egal
das hat ja doch du willst du 200
millionen erbeutet
nein ich 200 millionen erbeuteten
bankrat begangen oder sondern bak
konspiration steuerbetrug und eine
mission und toiletten ohne druck dort
und automatisch gelangt und hätten eine
salve das maß für agno und wenn man mit
einer wahren gesichter machten
als er jetzt sagen dass man die haut
trocken auf wie konnte es soweit kommen
die geschichte beginnt am 14 mai 2002 in
zürich in der finanzwelt ist alles in
bester ordnung noch die ubs gibt bekannt
sie bauen ihre führung aus der neue chef
beim private banking international
heisst raul weil er ist herr über
milliarden von kundenvermögen er hat er
seine 1,5 billionen das gesendete
tralien sinn eigentlich also mini
division since wald wie über 60
mitarbeiter sei zum damaligen zeitpunkt
eine bilderbuchkarriere doch am 12
november 2008 endet sie abrupt damals so
verschafft heißt sie metro stimmen an
den zoologen gramm von sich zieht und
dann bin ich mal allround gesehen ganz
quadra und uns uns geld für dürfen wenn
man die blüten oder und damalige chef
wenn man eine ableitung zeitlos
amerikaner und wieder in stationen
weiter verfolgen bietet mir kurz und 6
wienerisch und zeitlose schlacht die
noch richtig bevor amerika klopp dort
und da bin ich so schnell wenn wir keine
ruft sie zurück folgt das ganze rein
geschlossen bleiben muss seine website
am himmel sehen die ganze auch glaube er
hat ein sofortiges stand traten oder das
schlagzeug unterricht mit einem ins
spiel zurück wenige monate zuvor
21 april 2008 ein mitarbeiter von raul
weil lautet in miami und wird dort
sofort festgenommen
dieser mann hat damals den haftbefehl
unterzeichnet der ehemalige staatsanwalt
und heutige star verteidiger jeffrey
nehmen
[Musik]
die usa haben die möglichkeit einen
speziellen haftbefehl für zeugen zu
erlassen
das wird aber nur in spezialfällen getan
im us- fall haben wir das genutzt es war
wie einige sagen würden eine aggressive
taktik der staatsanwaltschaft zu einer
zeit in der es nicht üblich war zuvor zu
gehen
der festgenommene banker muss vor einem
untersuchungsausschuss des
amerikanischen senats auftreten
der nächste vorgeladene heißt martin
lerch ich hoffe ich spreche ihren namen
richtig aus martin liechti hier links im
bild läutete das amerika geschäft der
ubs schwören sie feierlich vor gott dass
sie vor diesem untersuchungsausschuss
die wahrheit und nichts als die wahrheit
sagen ich schwöre herr vorsitzender auf
anraten meines anwalts verweigere ich
höflich gestützt auf die us-verfassung
die beantwortung ihrer fragen
dem us staatsanwalt hingegen gibt er
später auskunft er sagt er habe raul war
wiederholt auf problematische
offshore-konten hingewiesen
das exekutivkomitee habe sich danach
darum gekümmert damit sei es für ihn
erledigt gewesen denn er habe dort
keinen einsatz gehabt frau war dagegen
schon
die beschuldigung wirkt unter anderem
deshalb klar die us justiz weil an
ich denke die anklage gegen raul weil
zeigte klar auf welche beweise die
staatsanwaltschaft gegen die bank saß
und es bestehen keine zweifel dass dies
großen druck auf die bank aus siebte
sodass sie begann mit der
staatsanwaltschaft zu kooperieren
liefert die achtzehnte februar 2009 die
entscheidende bundesratssitzung
der bundesrat um was geht es die
verfügung die gestern erlassen wurde
sieht vor dass die finma daten von
kunden der ubs bei denen gemäss der bank
verdacht auf steuerbetrug nach
schweizerischem recht besteht an das
department of justice herausgeben wird
und da wirklich eine das ganze gebäude
darf
der usb stick mit den daten wurde einer
person in der botschaft in zürich
überreicht die dann nach washington
dort traf ich sie mit meinen
staatsanwalt kollegen und den usa kennt
wir erhielten einen sogenannten
diplomatischen behälter das ist
eigentlich ein behälter mit einem roten
kissen das den zoll ohne kontrolle
passieren kann
erstaunlich ein rotes kissen gelegt
wir erhielten also diesen usb stick und
es war ein ziemlich historischer moment
für uns staatsanwälte wir hatten
geschafft was zuvor noch niemandem
gelungen war
die ubs liefert rund 290 kundendaten und
zahlt eine buße von circa 900 millionen
franken
damit ist für sie das schlimmste
überstanden
ihr ex manager raul war jedoch wird
jahre später in bologna verhaftet und
sitzt seit wochen in diesem gefängnis in
auslieferungshaft richtung usa 1 2
stellte handel gesehen und da schon
mehrmals mehrmals ich saßen also als 130
sehen sich versorgen die ferien
touristik sie mit 118 amtsverhältnis
counterpart lebenslauf dann mit samuel
koch zu europa
[Musik]
im gefängnis ist ein relativ langweilig
das ist aber für stinker lange einigung
wenn wir fangen tagebuch 439 idee
gebracht schrieb es unheimlich tagebuch
führen und vielleicht allenfalls das
ganze so schrieb das ist gerade freunde
und familien aus handy und dann jeweils
werbefilm sieht ackermann und schreibe
und erinnerte und faulheit in schutz
wenn es am morgen auf einmal eine mit
franks vater mit taschenlampe ins
gesicht blendet und gezahlt weil auf
strom
wenn es losgegangen sind nacht und die
mini browser zusammen ist viertklässler
verfrachtet worden
aber eben nicht fahren das sind 8
betrages einbruchs und ein andermal
bands und dort an den bereits zwei
amerikanische kette die marshals wartet
wir haben in seinem buch aufgelegt und
lounge alle der drau festgemacht und in
center gehören und eine wichtige norm
als kommerzielles flugzeug laufen
ausgeliefert wird das hammer christ will
rhj will ich an all das aber braucht auf
italien 2 30 dollar aber brachten und
mit einem slip usk wurde in vancouver
zum einen was genau von hand ist es ein
mini christ oder aber mindestens einmal
denn die unsicherheit der weg und das
110 an
[Musik]
er trug einen orangen gefangenen anzug
als er in den usa ankommen und er war
gefesselt mit handschellen und captain
an den beinen als ob er terrorist wäre
doch er war wegen eines steuerdelikts
angeklagt und noch nicht einmal
verurteilt
die regierung behandelte ihn und
staatsfeind nummer eins das war
lächerlich und nur dazu bestimmt druck
auf ihn auszuüben
in den usa beantragt raul war hauser ist
statthaft nach einigen gefängnis tagen
wird er dem richter vorgeführt
[Musik]
frühes besser erzogen und den rasierer
handschellen und dann ist eine rückwand
lehrer getroffen hat gestand ist
wordpress und der medical car das machen
sie auch gezielt das ist richtig
vorgeführt wird quasi im anmarsch der
andere weg machen und dass er weg macht
es war eine schreckliche zeit für die
alles schien gegen ihn gerichtet unsere
regierung war bestens vorbereitet um ihn
zu verurteilen
einen so hohen banker auf der
anklagebank da wollten sie keine
niederlage erleben sie war wild
entschlossen ihn sofort in diese
situation kommen zwei weitere personen
ins spiel und machte geschickt
vielleicht bin japaner aber seine sache
passiert ist und ich gar nicht wolle
dass das da versuchen abgewürgt wird
bevor sie überhaupt die möglichkeit
haben sich dazu zu äußern
der brief war sie interessant er begann
mit den worten ihr bleibt immer unsere
freunde und wir schätzen eure
freundschaft
ich werde dir eine frage stellen und
wenn du nein sagst ist es okay sie
werden freunde bleiben und dann schrieb
sie wäre es möglich dass sierau
hausarrest offerieren könnte wenn er
einen solchen erhält ich wusste ein
brief würde zu lange dauern
also schrieb ich eine mail ich mag
dieses positive wort ja in
großbuchstaben
ich wusste sie würde sofort verstehen
dass ich ja sagt ihr dazu dass raul bei
uns wohnen könnte ich wusste sie würde
es herausfinden wir sind sehr verbunden
die us-richter gewehr zwar hausarrest
doch er lässt harte auflagen rief aus
florida an und sagte wir haben gute und
schlechte nachrichten
er sagte wie hoch die kaution war sie
war ziemlich hoch dann sagte er zu hause
rispe und sei zwar gemischt jedoch der
richter verlangte dass ihr haus als
sicherheit hinterlegen würden so dass
wenn raul flüchten würde der staat das
haus beschlagnahmen könnte hatte ich das
gesagt antwortete brender
natürlich werden wir uns als sicherheit
hinterlegen er erwiderte möchtest du
nicht schon fragen und ich antwortete
erhöhen was denkst du wer ist der
basiert ich muss sagen es rührt mich zu
tränen dass sie uns so großzügig und so
vertrauenswürdig einem freund gegenüber
sein kann oder auch nur zu zögern
das war ein wunderbarer beweis ihrer
liebe für raul und zusammen und
unglaublich großzügig denn dadurch 120
seelen dorf haben innerhalb von größeren
von garten bewegen oder wenn ihre eltern
aber zum zahnarzt wenn man hier spezial
bewilligung ist nie vorbei
das war sein bereich hatten john und ich
hier unser fernsehzimmer sein
schlafzimmer war hier das war früher
unseres aber als die kinder weg waren
zogen wir nach oben
und hier bereitete er sich auf den
prozess
[Musik]
wir schauten zu wie ruhig und beherrscht
weitermachte trotz aller widrigkeiten
ich bin sicher er war innerlich
angespannt und nervös
aber er gab uns mehr als wir ihm glauben
ich sage wir die widrigkeiten meisterte
wir standhaft
wir fragten uns ob er unser leben ein
bisschen auf den kopf stellen würde
aber er passte perfekt zu uns er ist ein
wunderbarer mensch genau wie susan wenn
man an einem so hochrangige manager
denkt stellt man ihn sich immer
hochnäsig und arrogant vor aber nicht
raus
wundervoll sehr bodenständig und
einfühlsam
es war einfach angenehm
wir fühlten uns was die brüder und zu
knobeln sometimes barclays die smi bis
behindert mit richtig schnelle schürze
wird auch ob es hätten dort lang zu
winken die vier möglich machen auf deine
30 meter von ihrem haus aus vertrauen
weil regelmäßig mit dem linienbus nach
new york ins büro seiner anwälte auch
ungefähr bei kilometer hat mir gps
überwachungssystemen yamaha haltung
gestellt von hughes empfangen
sie bereiten gemeinsam den prozess vor
diese zwei stunden community unter
ständiger bewachung kam es auf dem
charakter stark ohne zwischenhalt in ein
anwaltsbüro wir wussten es gab hunderte
von interviews mit 50 bis 80 zeugen
aber wir wussten nicht was drin stand
der prozess drohte zu einer riesigen
überraschung zu werten wenn diese zeugen
aussagen würden millionen dokumente
deckt oder das muss man sich mal
vorstellen dass so voneinander
begeistert denn ist das ein akt so hoch
wie empire state building und mindert
vielleicht 50 20 liter glas und
schlussendlich mehr haben sie ungefähr
500 sie sieht den soho marisa bock
lektor mal dass ich jetzt der landkarte
von ihm gerichtsprozesse sind wir 500
zentrale dokument sie versucht in einer
sitzung logisch und genau thematisch so
zu ordnen dass man jederzeit
zusammenhang feststelle zwischen
verschiedenen gegebenheiten oder und
involvierte person
allein die prozess vorbereitungen in new
york kosten millionen von franken
darüber sprechen mögen die anwälte
allerdings nicht gern
[Musik]
es war ziemlich teuer
um einer person einen fairen prozess zu
garantieren muss man leider genauso
viele ressourcen wie die us regierung
haben
das ist sehr teuer und sehr selten
obwohl wir nicht mehr ressourcen als die
regierung hatten hatten wir aber mehr
mittel als ein durchschnitts
strafverteidiger engagiert denn auch
mario mentel und adriana riviera zwei
spezialisten viel kreuzverhöre das ist
ein großes team normalerweise hat die
regierung mehr ressourcen als die
verteidigung sie haben drei
staatsanwälte viele agenten viele
finanzanalysten
normalerweise kann man das auf der
verteidigung seid ihr nicht ausgleichen
aber in diesem fall konnten wir das und
ja es war sehr sehr teuer millionen von
dollars also was ist genial co steht das
weiß ich nicht aber es ist sehr
substanziellen betrag singen und du bist
schlussendlich müssen zahlen also alle
drachen zu sichern
probier's einfach mal begaben
die anwälte und raul wahlkämpfen sich in
new york durch tausende von dokumenten
und dann stoßen sie plötzlich auf eine
überraschung
eines tages nachdem wir wieder eine
sammlung von dokumenten der regierung
gehalten hatten fand ein anwalt aus
meinem team einen entwurf einer
eidesstattlichen erklärung von martin im
jahr 2008 als sich die festgenommen
wurde wollte die regierung von ihm dass
er jude es angestellte belastet
hauptsächlich seinen chef frauen war und
sechs jahre später hatten wir an entwurf
dieser erklärung dass die regierung
dieses dokument unbeabsichtigt in die
sammlung gelegt hatte ich bat meine
mitarbeiter der das papier entdeckt
hatte raul zu informieren damit wir das
besprechen konnten
es war ein toller hund verborgenen
millionen von dokumenten die die
regierung uns über richte dann endlich
am 14 oktober 2014 beginnt der prozess
in florida in fort lauderdale einem
städtchen nahe bei miami
die staatsanwaltschaft versucht vorher
noch dem prozess auszuweichen
sie haben hier offeriert als letzte und
beste kinounterhaltung - zwei monate
gefängnis in bologna und damit war in
amerika und kriminalisiert worden hat
und das kann ich einfach nicht auf mir
sitzen
ich bitte meine dass ich mich vor
zweifachen und in einen gemeinsamen
frauen die hand dann beschlossen oder
das macht
es ist der allererste gerichtsprozess im
steuerkonflikt usa schweiz
vorher haben alle angeklagten oder
unternehmen einen deal ausgehandelt
auftritt von zeuge martin liechti
er hat mit der staatsanwaltschaft
vereinbart er geht straffrei aus
auch wenn er sich selbst belastet
voraussetzung er sagt die wahrheit
zeichnungen aus dem gerichtssaal
aufnahmen mit kamera sind untersagt
richter james cohn eröffnet er ließ die
sie stehen unter ein staatsanwalt daily
beginnt nun mit der befragen
herrlich die dieses mail ist auch an sie
adressiert darin heißt es die ubs muss
sofort handeln um sich vor einer
möglichen strafe zu schützen
es geht unter anderem um offshore
kreditkarten haben sie raul weil darüber
informiert das war ein thema bei unseren
treffen unter vier augen herr
staatsanwalt wenig später ich sagte ihm
bei diesen persönlichen treffen auch je
mehr aktivitäten wie in den usa haben
desto größer ist das risiko dass etwas
auf liegt wie meinen sie das erlebt
wir hatten angst vor
zeitungsschlagzeilen die wiederum die us
justiz zu einer untersuchung hätten
animieren können
wenig später erlief die haben sie
darüber mit herrn weil gesprochen
wir waren freunde ich informierte herrn
weil dass wir gegen die eigenen regeln
verstoßen
es war ein müden dies immer wieder zu
wiederholen
ich denke die regierung hat sich auf
martin wierig die als belastungszeuge
fokussiert weil dieser direkt an raul
weil rapportierte während der befragung
erwähnte herrlich die sogenannte
bilaterale meetings das waren treffen
unter vier augen zwischen ihm und raul
war und er sagt ihr während dieser
treffen habe er bedenken über die
geschäftspraktiken der bank in
nordamerika geäußert dann übernimmt der
kreuzverhör spezialist winkel herrlich
die bahn unter anderem für nordamerika
zuständig waren sie oft unterwegs sehr
oft ich war rund zwei bis drei wochen im
monat unterwegs
wenig später fällig die sie haben dem
gericht vorhin gesagt sie hätten raul
weil wegen des mails gewarnt mündlich
schriftlich das management entschied
dass wir die mail flut eindämmen sollten
deshalb sahen wir uns im büro und
diskutierten
eigentlich brauchen wir jeden tag über
diese probleme herr verteidiger haben
sie gesagt jeden tag jeden tag wann
immer wir im büro waren es die richtige
später selber zu dass er sich ungefähr
zwei bis drei wochen pro monat nicht in
der schweiz aufhielt und auch herr
weinbau viel abwesend die vorstellung
die bei den geschworenen entstand wonach
die beiden sich regelmäßig unter vier
augen trafen und legt die hand weil dort
über problematische geschäfte
informierte macht einfach keinen sinn
wenn sie den geschworenen erklären sie
hätten jeden tag mit raul wahl
gesprochen dann ist das wohl nicht ganz
korrekt richtig ich bin hier um die
wahrheit zu sagen wir haben uns leid
meine agenda in fünf jahren 51 mal auf
diese weise getroffen
die vorstellung dass diese persönlichen
treffen regelmäßig stattfanden war
unsinn und die geschworenen verstanden
dass der nächste belastungszeuge der
schweizer banker hans wird die
schumacher die links im bild
wie lief die wird auch er nicht
strafrechtlich verfolgt wenn er sich
selbst belastet voraussetzung er sagt
die wahrheit
staatsanwalt daily beginnt mit der
befragung
herr schumacher wie organisierte die ubs
ihr us geschäft
die meisten der 15.000 us kunden zahlten
keine steuern das wussten wir in der
bank sieht deklarierten ihr geld nicht
wenig später ist es richtig dass sie
herr schumacher beabsichtigt haben von
der ubs das geschäft mit diesen
schwarzgeldern zu übernehmen
richtig herr staatsanwalt ich habe diese
frau war persönlich mitgeteilt
wusste er dass es um schwarzgeld ging ja
sicher ich habe ihm das klar gesagt
hatte er irgendwelche bedenken nein
überhaupt nicht aber ihm gefiel die idee
nicht so richtig dass ich dieses
geschäft übernehmen
ich habe kurz darauf gekündigt und bin
zu einer anderen bank gegangen
rené später haben sie damals versucht
jubi es kunden abzuwerben
ja sicher einer davon war die swissair
hatte unversteuerte 45 millionen dollar
auf seinem konto ich bin nach manhattan
geflogen und habe ihn dort getroffen
waren sie erfolgreicher schumacher
leider nein sagte mir und meine
begleiter hätte zuvor besuch erhalten
von raul weil unter einem kollegen beide
hätten ihn überzeugt sein unversteuertes
geld sei bei der ubs sicher
wenn die geschworenen dies geglaubt
hätten wäre herr weil wegen verschwörung
zum steuerbetrug verurteilt worden das
hätte genügt susanne erich wirth
beigezogen
matthew und die anderen anwälte haben in
den unterlagen der staatsanwaltschaft
geschwärzte us- dokumente gefunden ist
truth wins eventuell dort erwähnt
da steckt viel mehr als wir sehen und es
zeigte sich dass die meisten us-
dokumente nummern enthielten und keine
namen
wir fanden informationen über eine
newbies kunden die eine dieser
speziellen strukturen besonders damit er
keine us steuern zahlen musste sony capt
in der hoffnung dass sie vielleicht
unter dem schwarzen die kulturen und
macher von buchstabe ist natürlich nicht
möglich sie den hamas leuten die
geschwärzte stelle klasse und hat die
einzelne buchstabe masse und glück habe
ich das hat sich irgendwie es ist auch
möglich und der vertrag vor dass e mails
lese und es dann in informationen wonach
sie sind voll kriegt schließen überdies
einen oft stellen sie schon rundgang
in basel sich für ihre längere zeit
nicht mehr korrekt wohlhabende hund mit
wenig geschafft als macht heimbach es
geht eigentlich nur zwei gründe so
aufbrausend und antwortet uhren und
schmuck
sie fügte die teile so zusammen dass wir
realisierten der kunde hieß robbins herr
schumacher sind sie sicher dass herr
weil sich mit jools robbins traf robin
sagt es mir selber her verteidiger sehen
sie dieses juwels dokument ja es zeigt
welche ubs angestellten zur fraglichen
zeit mit gil robbins zusammentrafen
sehen sie den namen raul weil nein
die schweizer sind bekannt dafür dass
die aufzeichnung und detailliert führen
die ubs zeichnete alle kontakte zu ihren
kunden auf als wir das dokument
lokalisiert hatten zeigte sich herr weil
stand nie in kontakt mit herrn robert
martini ist die hingegen schon herrlich
die lassen sie uns dieses dokument
anschauen das ist eine information für
sie über herrn robbins sehr freundlicher
mann bei uns seit vielen jahren kommt
regelmäßig nach basel an die uhrenmesse
richtig das steht hier wenig später hier
steht sie hätten jools robbins damals
getroffen richtig das ist was ich hier
lesen kann
ich bin nicht sicher ob ich wusste dass
wir diesen beweis besaßen wir konnten im
kreuzverhör zeigen dass nicht herbei
sondern herrlich die sich mit herrn
robbins traf wir konnten also schon am
anfang des prozesses der regierung ein
ernsten schlag versetzen
um dies zu verstehen ist eine rückblende
nötig die schweizer banken also auch die
ubs schlossen damals mit den us
steuerbehörden ein abkommen das
sogenannte qualified intermediary kurz
qi abkommen es gilt seit dem ersten
januar 2001 es war das wichtigste
dokument in diesem prozess ist riesig
und sehr kompliziert schwierig zu
verstehen
es geht vor allem um steuern ein großes
durcheinander
das q abkommen verlangt wenn ein us
bürger wie robbins us aktien besitzt
muss die bank die amerikanische
steuerbehörde irs informieren
schwarzgeld gibt es nicht mehr wenn der
kunde jedoch seine us-wertpapiere sofort
verkauft muss die bank sein schwarzgeld
nicht deklarieren verwalter eingeklagt
verschwörung zu ungunsten der usa
begangen zu haben das bedeutet dass er
etwas getan oder dabei geholfen hatte
die usa zu täuschen
ein wichtiger teil der vorwürfe der
us-regierung bezog sich auf das
klimaabkommen drehte sich also um us
bürger die ihre us aktien verkauften und
das geld anders an legten damit sie ihre
konten nicht deklarieren mussten das
klimaabkommen erlaubte dass es war ein
kompromiss zwischen der amerikanischen
steuerbehörde irs und den schweizer
banken doch kunden wie robbins wollten
mehr konnten ohne us aktien fanden sie
nicht attraktiv
findige anwälte schieben deshalb als
angeblichen eigentümer eine stiftung
zwischen konto und us-bürger und so
kamen die falschen strukturen ächtung
sie erlaubten die us aktien zu behalten
indem der richtige eigentümer gegenüber
der us-regierung verschleiert wurde
gegen aussen ist jetzt beispielsweise
eine bahamas oder liechtenstein stiftung
eigentümer insgeheim aber bestimmt der
us bürger also robbins nach wie vor was
mit dem geld geschieht zum beispiel als
liechtenstein ich beherrsche oder
schweizer die sich in daten wahrheit ist
aber eine amerikanische steuerpflichtige
der innengestaltung wehrpflichtig sie
verkleinern das delikt in diesem prozess
beginnen
kunden die die us aktien behalten aber
nicht deklarieren wollten was die bank
in schwierigkeiten brachte war dass es
sich für eine sogenannte kreative lösung
entschied
diese lautete wir behalten unsere us
aktien bezahlen jedoch keine höheren
steuern und wir sagen nicht wer wir sind
und wir machten sie das sie gründeten
diese falschen schein strukturen
schon damals war klar ein illegales
umgehungsgeschäfte deshalb der code
kreative lösungen
[Musik]
hier konnten wir beweisen raul weil
hatte nichts damit zu tun ist geschah
viel tiefer stufe schumacher sie haben
dafür das wort kreative lösungen benutzt
richtig richtig ein code der verteidiger
um das klimaabkommen zu umgehen
richtig sie haben geschrieben
vertraulich sie wollten dass niemand
außerhalb ihres bereiches davon erfuhr
richtig
es war wie in einem boxkampf
er hielt schlag um schlag und ab einem
gewissen punkt war er so am ende dass
man ihn irgendetwas hätte fragen können
zum beispiel schlägst du auch deine frau
und er antwortet ich tue auch dass sie
herr schumacher wollten das geschäft
nicht verlieren
richtig wer wusste davon die
kundenberater alle kundenberater in
meinem team und über ihnen niemand
es gibt einen sehr dramatischen teil in
diesem prozess so etwas sieht man im
fernsehen und denkt in einem richtigen
prozess passiert das nie dann dreht sich
mehr zuzutrauen zeigt auf ihn und sagt
dieser mann raul weil hatte nichts damit
zu tun richtig richtig das war ein
moment extreme konzentration
wir hatten keine ahnung dass das frauen
würde eine sehr überraschende moment
aber schumacher gab zu dass er die
verbrechen über die er sprach mit raul
diskutiert
es war also sehr wirkungsvoll das war
vernichtend für die staatsanwaltschaft
herr schumacher hatte soeben zugegeben
dass ihr und diejenigen unter ihm ist
gemacht haben
aber raul weil nichts von diesen
strukturen wusste dass ich ganz klarer
verstoß gegen richtlinien anzuschließen
der bisherigen reform toleriert worden
weiter hat sich gegen die hre klagt
herrlich die gewisse personen halfen us
bürgern falsche strukturen falsche
stiftungen aufzusetzen
richtig das passiert in diesem geschäft
haben sie herrlich die es getan ich habe
nie so etwas getan wenn ich eine
scheinfirma gründe um das amerikanische
steuergesetz zu umgehen ist das ihrer
meinung nach kriminellen richtig und
wenn eine bank dabei hilft unterstützte
eine kriminelle handlung richtig gut wir
wissen aus diesem dokument des igels
robbins getroffen haben korrekt herrlich
ding das ist was hier steht mit den
dokumenten die zusagen zu lokalisieren
11 konnten wir zeigen
der mann der juice robbins half dies
martin liechti hier heißt es robbins hat
eine hongkong firma eröffnet über eine
liechtensteiner stiftung er trifft alle
entscheidungen selbst das ist doch genau
jene struktur die unter dem klo abkommen
verbot war korrekt das ließ sich jetzt
ich bin nicht sicher was ich im jahr
2002 darüber wusste dieses interne
jubels dokumente robbins wurde doch für
sie herrlich die für dieses treffen
erstellt richtig es geht genau um solche
strukturen die unter dem qi abkommen
verboten waren korrekt im rückblick ja
aber damals hatte ich nicht diesen
information statt
entschuldigung ich verstehe nicht das
dokument wurde ja erstellt damit sie
alles über robbens wissen ich war damals
nicht in alle details des abkommens
eingeweiht
damals war meine einzige sorge dass wir
tools robbins als kunde nicht verlieren
auf der einen seite sagte er habe sich
nicht falsch verhalten
oder er sei sich keines fehlverhaltens
bewusst auf der anderen seite
beschuldigte er raul weil dieser habe
von fehlverhalten gewusst von dem er
sich die nichts gewusst haben will
das ergab keinen sinn denn herrlich die
rapportierte an herr weil wenn also legt
die nichts von fehlverhalten wusste oder
nichts falsch machte wie konnte er dann
darüber an raul weil berichten
das war also ein innerer widerspruch in
seinen aussagen und wir konnten dies
immer wieder aufzeigen
die letzte nacht vor die motoren und
einer schlaftablette knolle school die
geschworenen treffen ein und nach einem
kurzen auftakt ziehen sie sich zur
beratung zurück
also da nix sagt normalerweise oder
bucht jury in der strophe form weil sie
eine einstimmigkeit erzielt werden also
alle zwölf geschworenen sich einig
semotan und die buchen normale ist
ungefähr ein tag pro pizza suche zu
unsicher
das beruhte das heißt mit einer erwartet
dass es über drei tage warten bis ich
die ja einig sind und wirklich einig
sind und wenn sie mehrere offen gericht
gegangen und eine pizzeria fahrrädern um
über 45 minuten unter verhandelt
gerichts den ort und seinen namen nicht
weiß was jetzt los ist ob es nach
falkenberg
wir kommen also wieder hören
unter richter saß bereits er kündigte an
die geschworenen hätten ein urteil wird
als rwe spieler dachten dies wäre ein
fall der eine lange beratungszeit
beanspruchen würde außer wenn die
geschworenen den sollten nicht glaubten
gilt ist eine schwere last von der
schulter
richtig durchgeschüttelt jetzt die ganze
fünf tore geschüttelt aber das jetzt
richtig durchgeschüttelt
natürlich sind uns in allen gefallen und
minen sind planen aber das ist
unbeschreiblich
trotz man anweisungen und all unseren
besten absichten sprangen alle in die
luft
die richter erlaubte uns dann diesen
jubel
obwohl das nicht gerade konform mit
korrektem verhalten vor gericht
die schaute rübe zu raul und lächelte
ihn zu er umarmt seine frau
er war zwar überwältigt aber trotzdem
noch genauso wie ich raul in erinnerung
hatte
sie beherrscht ein typischer schweizer
mann er war glücklich aber er weinte
nicht
währenddessen waren die anwälte außer
uns die erleichterung und die freude
dass frau und seine freiheit zurück
erlangen würde waren unglaublich
das ist ein moment unbeschreibliche
hochstimmung bin ich nie vergessen wird
griffin auch ein paar tränen runter wir
waren alle überglücklich ich war sehr
emotional näher kamen die trainer sie
müssen verstehen das war nicht einfach
ein fall in dem wir dachten die
regierung hätte versagt das war ein fall
in dem wir glaubten dass herr weil
wirklich unschuldig ist
die verantwortung auch auf emotionaler
ebene ist in so einem fall gegenüber den
klienten es ist unsere aufgabe als
strafverteidiger jeden zu verteilen egal
ob er ein verbrechen begangen hat oder
nicht
aber wenn man von ganzem herzen glaubt
dass die person es nicht getan hat
fiebert man umso mehr mit denn wenn die
geschworenen mit einem anderen urteil
zurück kämen würde man sie vorwerfen
man hätte vielleicht nicht alles für den
klienten getan ich erinnere mich also
sehr gut an diesem moment
[Musik]
ich denke die verteidigung hat sich
unglaubliche mühe gegeben den fall für
die geschworenen surfer komplizierten
prozess konzentrierte sich auf das
klimaabkommen es bis heute niemand auf
der welt richtig versteht war ich
überrascht vom urteil nochmals die
verteidigung hat eine große leistung
vollbracht die geschworenen zu
überzeugen dass er unschuldig ist
steuerbetrugs fälle sind immer schwierig
sie sind für die regierung schwierig zu
beweisen meint all4 strafverteidiger
weil sie so schwierig für die regierung
zu beweisen sind die staatsanwaltschaft
hier beim verlassen des gerichts hat auf
eine schriftliche interview anfragen
nicht reagiert
martin liechti wurde nie angeklagt oder
verurteilt
er lehnte ein interview
über seinen anwalt teilte mit er können
den freispruch von rauball nicht
nachvollziehen
hansruedi schumacher bekennt sich
schuldig dass amerikanische steuergesetz
auch in anderen fällen verletzt zu haben
und wird mit 150000 franken busse
bestraft er teilt mit die us justiz habe
ihm untersagt sich zum fall wahl zu
äußern
[Musik]
verstanden dass ihnen in deiner
situation
optimismus kann hat und natürlich legen
wir also ich glaube dass in südafrika
bis positives grünen ist oder denn war
der fall
nicht nur schwierig saison also
eigentlich nicht gestoppt
heute arbeitet raul weil als
selbstständige vermögensberater
allerdings nur noch drei tage die woche
[Musik]